I want to reduce something to a score
but you gave this game a 10 out of 10 on
a game spot which means it is essential
to the central game so if you're
watching this or somehow coming across
the video you should play supermario
I'll see if you have any passing
interest in video games and if you have
a switch yet walk me through it what
where's why is this such a great 3d
platformer when when when Mario is known
for these with two marks before Super
Mario Galaxy games Super Mario Sunshine
you know I don't really like well it's
very different from all those games
despite sort of having the same general
3d platformer premise and more than
anything Super Mario de si is a is a
playground for discovery and you know
the whole deal is like you're collecting
moons and and in the past maybe you
would set out in certain levels like
collect a star and you get sent back to
the beginning like this game like you
know you find one moon you continue the
next one and if you're you're really
aware of what you're doing and you're
really aware of what Mario is capable of
and that includes how he can use his
environments and enemies to his
advantage you can find a moon and thus
feel rewarded like every other minute
and when you're doing that you're also
going through like you know these
environments that seem somewhat small
like on paper but once you're actually
moving and shaking within them there's
so much to see and do and it just it
just feels sort of like a never-ending
never-ending like hunt for these things
and discovery for what the game has that
maybe you didn't see immediately this
game is just like playing with your
endorphins as you're getting like a moon
or coins or purple coins or finding some
sort of secret every like 30 seconds I
feel right and you're using that to go
to open up new world now to get a new
outfit for Mario you know no good no you
go I was to say but that endorphin like
[ __ ] I don't know that was a moon dude
there are so many like you just you just
can't even begin to spoil it like what I
wasn't saying is that you know not that
it's a bad thing but like as the game
progresses and you you know you you get
past that main quests like those
endorphins are still there but like you
find yourself like really kind of
working a
harder to get these moons like they come
they do open up a new set of moons and
they literally tell you where they are
yeah but then it's yes like after that
which is sort of the post game and then
the real post game yeah you could beat
the game with what is it 250 moons I
think it's like like someone did a
speedrun recently in like 80 something
minutes I think they had about 90 moons
[ __ ] I have a I think I have more than
that I'm only on the snow Kingdom right
now yeah I mean as you can have more
than that yeah so the game basically
shows you like okay we need this many
moons to power your ship to get to the
next Kingdom and once you visit every
Kingdom then you kind of get to the end
and you can get there pretty quickly if
you just sort of follow the required
moon counts and then proceed to your
next step but you know I beat the game
with like 150 moons and there were 700
left for me to find I'm currently at 520
ish and that's sort of like the last big
milestone the game sets for you is 500
so I'm beyond that at this point but I'm
still enjoying the game and I'm still
you know playing it every now and then I
did put in like like 40 to 50 hours and
just like four days or something like
that three or four days so it was kind
of a lot for a minute but it's it says a
lot that I can keep going back to this
game and I don't really tire of it yeah
I think our friend over at Giant Bomb
Dan Reicher found all the moons correct
well friend I guess but yeah he went
pretty crazy on this game ma'am that's
very like him to do that alright so let
me ask you this before you guys had
finished or at least before you had
gotten up so like the 600 or sorry like
400 something moons you're saying a lot
of it is easy
maybe that's beside the point but if you
wanna talk about the difficulty cuz I am
finding it is very easy overall and I'm
not like especially great at platformers
I'm pretty decent at this game but it's
obviously it's very inventive it's very
creative it just kind of like plays of
your imagination and what you can think
of these environments but that's the
challenge right and also but there are
there are some platforming parts where
you're going through those cap doors and
then getting on those rockets to launch
into space for those harder platforming
sections did you feel the difficulty was
uh was like well tailored throughout
yeah and I actually think there's a much
bigger discussion that we should
have here which is sort of the opposite
of what I think everyone was talking
about a couple weeks ago like difficult
games are great in their own way well so
are games that are that are very
forgiving and easy in a sense like I
think Mario is the perfect argument for
why both types of games can exist like
yeah even if you fail in the sections
that you're talking about you're not
actually losing much except for the time
you spent to die like and coins you can
easily get back yeah like the coins are
so easy to get and even when you run out
of coins and total like there's no such
thing as a game over in this screen that
doesn't exist there's no 1up mushroom
there's no lives as it were like this is
abandoned anything that made Mario is
sort of like if you can call it that
like a threatening experience where you
can put so much time and energy into
something and then not get there and
have to start a whole kingdom or world
over mmm and just feel like man that's
really frustrating does that mean this
game is bad because it's easy I would
say no unless you you need to prove
something or you can only enjoy
difficult games like this game can be
surprisingly difficult when it comes to
the puzzle solving which is really how
you use Mario and the environment to
acquire the moon that you can see but
you're like how the hell do I get to it
so it can be surprisingly challenging in
those ways towards the very end of the
game you do unlock some stuff that is
sort of like a gauntlet where if you die
there's no checkpoint you have to go
back to the beginning and that takes the
form of a boss rush and is a really
difficult series of platforming sections
and in that sense it seems to harken
back to something like mario 64 where it
is so much about the platforming and
really a test of your skill this is more
a test of your strategizing in execution
in so many ways even like met your
ability to switch up your perspective
which I think kind of helps in this game
yeah yeah there are there are certain
times where it helps to really like line
it up into a 2d perspective and not just
the retro sections but like even when 3d
platforming or go to a top-down
perspective as well and even just
challenging yourself to always change
the camera angle in your perspective
because that's the only way you can find
all the moons and that's the only way
towards the end of the game that you can
really make progress but that also makes
these seemingly small open worlds that
much more interesting because no matter
where you look you will ultimately be
facing something that is worth seeking
it's and it's yeah and and coming back
with a different perspective
a lot of times I've run into that where
like I've spent a lot of time on a
little mini game Mike you saw me
battling one the other day and it's
forgiving in a sense looks like you know
what
I'm just gonna come back because there's
so much to do in this playground as a
whole that I have no problem walking
away from things and that's where the
challenge is like is is bearable in my
perspective versus like yeah just a Kyle
comeback it's not prom there's so much
going on I can I can get more moons
somewhere else but you can you can
pretty much get any moon right from the
start if you know where it is and how to
like handle your environment Mars
outfits don't give him any special
powers
it's the any easy capture and they're
limited to these environments and you
can't take them out so you've got all
the tools you need to get the moon's
pretty much unless I'm forgetting I
would say like some of the worlds you'd
have to defeat a specific boss to like
get open up new areas to moons like sure
something like ability wise anything
speaking of abilities and whatnot so
he's got a pretty diverse skill set in
this game one thing that people were
worried about was like maybe in our
reliance on motion controls was that the
case here did you entirely option I
think that's been blown out of
proportion half to the review there's a
couple moves cuz Mario can throw his hat
obviously he can throw his hat in a few
different ways some of those extra ways
you can manage through button presses
other ones you have to use motion
controls in handheld mode throwing your
hat up or down isn't great and I don't
even know if it works to be honest with
you I've been able to do it properly
mostly cuz I don't want to like fling my
entire switch up and down holding it by
the controllers but the only times where
I had to do that was when there it was
like a couple moons I was like okay
clearly I need to shake to get my hat up
there because I can't jump that high so
I'd pop the joint cons off my switch and
just did it and put him back on it was
like 20 seconds over he done with if you
have a pro controller you can do
everything that you could with the joy
Collins so yeah there are a couple
forced motion controls things in here
that's not great like no one loves to be
forced to do that especially when it
seems like they probably could have
found a way to do it with buttons but
it's certainly not like an issue no well
yeah well there are some
the spin attack so if you're using the
joy Khans you flick both joy Kahn's to
either side simultaneously but if you're
playing on handle you could or even on a
regular troll you could just also rotate
the left stick right or you do it kind
of like you're in the older Zelda 3d
games you could either charge with B or
no spin the stick and that works with a
pro controller feels super natural
because you basically just like you let
go of one side of it hold to the other
handle and just sort of lick your wrist
it feels like you're throwing a freaking
hat yeah in a sense and so in that
respect it is you know a split second as
far as the timing right like it is
feasibly quicker to do this than it is
to do that spin move right because that
that's been moved with a hat circle
circles U is actually pretty vital like
for a lot of scenarios as far as like
help protection helpful
vital is taking it too far because the
game never requires it of you it that
presents it as like an efficiency thing
yes and that's what I was gonna say with
like that mundo you're talking about
that you couldn't get with the hat throw
yeah I wouldn't say like there is always
a way around that always like I've never
had the need where it's like I cannot
get here or grab this with without there
are in mind there are definitely a
couple moons we really do that you had
that problem where this is confirmed
yeah I know it's a thing it's all spin
move no there's another one like the
Frog if you shake the controller the
Frog does an extra flip and will jump a
little bit higher you can't get unless
you do that what can you describe that's
I can't there's also sorry there's also
the moon I think it's in the wooded
Kingdom where there's these it's it's
called a weird strange neighborhood and
the the platforms are moving like
apartments and you have to go back and
stack all the goombas I don't think you
can make some of those jumps without
shaking it because the goombas jump much
higher when you try it as opposed to
just the hop so I could definitely see
me I don't the moon I'm thinking of
particular maybe it's a dreaming about
other people I don't think I could have
done it without the shake jump with the
Goomba stack goombas I could be wrong
though but out to your point I can see
that being the case with our some moons
where you would need there's only two
that I can really think of where shaking
is required one of those in that Kingdom
one and then there's another one that
I'd forget where it was but yeah but
it's interesting you talk about how this
game kind of challenges your imagination
in terms of what you how you see the
levels because I think Mario Galaxy when
it came out was much more about those
smaller sand boxes and also be
kind of creative with how they used
three yeah there's a lot of like those
spherical worlds and I think both games
play with a 3d level design in an
awesome way
I mean Mario 64 did that's a precedence
forever but I didn't I don't I'm not a
huge fan of sunshine maybe I need to go
back to it I know that game has it's a
lot of defenders for people who aren't
super stoked on it just a lot of people
like that game but I love the Mario
Galaxy games and I think this game kind
of continues that legacy of 3d marios
playing with level design in a cool way
to your point it's very much every time
I go into a world I see it like an
aesthetic level and then I know there's
a ton that's gonna unfold before me yeah
I mean some of these places have over
100 moons yeah okay well maybe just one
I can think of but yeah if it gets that
high I mean I was I spent like maybe
five hours and toast arena town or not
the town what was the desert Kingdom
yeah but wait till toast arena town in
it
steam gardens where'd you saying I love
that song where would you say this I'm
not asking you for a definitive ranking
or list but say we go so 3d Mario games
Mario 64 Super Mario Sunshine Mario
Galaxy 1 & 2 if you want to do like 3d
World and 3d Land and factor those in
where does this fit on that list is it's
up there yeah I mean it's up there I can
only speak to my personal experience but
it's I find it really hard to compare
all those games because yeah they have
Mario and they have some other
consistent things but they're all very
different at their core they all offer
very different takes on 3d platforming
again despite the similarities you see
between them but you know if I if you
put all of them in front of me right now
I know I think I'd probably play Mario
64 in this the galaxy games are really
like sunshine didn't really do it for me
3d Land is interesting 3d world was a
little too messy with the multiplayer
stuff it wasn't required but I felt like
the game really it shined for that in
some ways but it also didn't succeed in
that way but if you talk about
multiplayer with this game as well
capi is an autonomous being like you
don't have to just be the second player
flicking the controller and that's it
you can separate from our his head and
go and do your own [ __ ] and troll Mario
if you want to as well I mean the
gameplay conceit of taking over other
creatures alone is enough that makes
this game fun even outside the level
design I mean they're showing in the the
wooded Kingdom I don't even know
what they are the sprouts that those are
the seeds that sprout the legs they go
there so fun to you held up roots and
then those caterpillars in the lost
kingdom that you stretch they're so fun
to use and Rob you said this is the
first time a while you've played a
platforming game where like you never
felt like the game was working against
you like you said like it may be such
good confidence in your precision oh
well yeah like there there was one
moment where it was a little in the
luncheon Kingdom where like oh yeah this
is just doing the multiplayer I actually
people were kind of ragging on this I
thought the two player to be pretty fun
I don't know I don't know how long I
mean I feel like I had to play more but
like for what it is and what it could
have been like it could have been just
like a tacked on like you know here
press a and you can like launch copy and
that's all you do as a second player
like you have a lot of control and I
think if you worked really well with
someone like you could do some like you
can do some moves that like I think
we're not you weren't able to in like by
yourself right like like you'd be you
could be both itasca at the same time
like I can be like getting coins as
Peters like you know jumping around
stopping on goombas or something like
that it was it was neat to see those
work stacking goombas is so fun yeah it
feels great yeah but I would say is yeah
there's a moment where like I so many
platforming games where you're you there
is a fear right like when you when
you're dealing with ultra precise
platforms you're trying to jump on and
land sometimes they're just these
moments and games where it's like you
know that the controller or the the
movement is ultra sensitive and you just
you have that like second-guess and you
fall off there are times we're like you
know platforms raising and lowering
we're like when lowered the area of that
I can step on is ultra small like I feel
like any other game I would have like
seen that like no I'm gonna wait I'm
gonna wait like that two three seconds
before I jump but like this game it was
like no I can totally I can totally nail
it and that happened like time and time
again where I was doing like pretty what
felt risky moves but just fully aware
that I can I can do anything like is it
is so natural
less like controlling Mario also like
one of the happiest games I've ever seen
it's like nygma theory and in the twitch
chat was saying yeah the difficulty
isn't in the platforming it's not the
porn game it's all about finding all
these collectibles and exploring and
that's if you want to consider it that
difficult that's how it fits in this
game and like you were just saying that
fits I don't think very very brutal
platforming would fit within what this
game is going for it well the the
sections they add in feel good because
they are sort of some of the only
distinct levels where like you enter a
pipe or a door and you end up in a
different place you're not really on the
map of the open world anymore so it
segments those sections from the main
game and I think it works especially
because they tend to come after you've
beaten the story the first time well not
the first time you beat the first major
storyline before moving on to what's
left if you will also this scene is a
pretty good example of how this game is
so freakin strange so hard this scene
where you just seen sheeple just going
from one door to the next like what are
they doing whoa is there like a meat
factory they're like falling into like
it's all inside of a building there is a
movie Factory in this town oh yeah I
just wanted to take those moons yeah
that was this is the first thing they
showed off right that you actually go to
like a real world not just the Mushroom
Kingdom
yeah but sorry I'm just realizing the
Moon factory established is why you can
just buy moons at the store oh my god
there you go
[ __ ] right Laura busted there no Laura
confirmed I don't know myth busted
nice alright anyway sorry Jake what I
was just gonna say one of the most
satisfying like possessions that I've
found or it's it's pretty obvious you'll
come across but that woodpecker
yep that like stick in and cuz I love
that mechanic and all I'm totally
licking the stick and you pokeo when you
combine that it's so much fun yeah and
the same goes for the Metro Kingdom New
York City just like the verticality of
all the buildings and all those poles
there's such joy and like you know I
think they're called pylons spark pylons
where you just you're zipping around
you're in midair clinging to a pole
flicking up
chasing a rabbit like it's so rewarding
just to like control Mario and just run
around that game like you get so
distracted it's great it does a really
good job of distilling I think I don't
want to say what makes video games great
as a whole but it really does sort of
give you a game that controls really
well makes you happy to be in its world
presents challenges but then doesn't
actually punish you for going out of
your comfort zone trying to get them
[Music]